good morning here's a
very nice sunny day again here in the uk
and um i was thinking about
the weapons and uh today i'd like to
talk about the ken
because while we're in this code
lockdown down very few
around the world were able to do
taijitsu
unless your partner that you live with
you can do it or you're in a bubble
all those empty dojos around the world
losing the energy from the walls it's
very sad
you hopefully you know what i mean
especially those of you who
own dojos must be a very sad time for
you
i remember one dojo i had i really
loved it in my garden my largest dojo
i used to go in there and even on a cold
day
the energy in the walls was still five
but not
warm you could get
a good fix just just walk into the dojo
you didn't really have to do much just
walk around
gaze not even think about aikido
but the one thing cytosensei told me
at an early stage
he gave me my ken and joey chosen for me
a great honor i still have them today
the joe's okay the ken's got a few
splinters
i'm lucky really because most people
would have shattered theirs by now
but i have had a lot of others in
between because i didn't want to
spoil them and wear them out but while i
was
following him for around about 20 years
i always took them with me because
my connection with him was my cannon
germ
on youtube i i see some really good
aikido weapons demonstrations
as i'm talking about the ken today
i watched them
and these um
these are not by walmart trained
students knowing their own
own right uh teachers
the obama can is handled very
differently and thought
very differently than
many of the kens that are taught in the
flowing arts
the flying arts of aikido the stars
they tend to do kashima bakken
iido style it's all about
fighting sword against sword
cutting opponents
where my belief is the obamacare is
totally
the opposite totally the opposite
it's all about where should my body be
at a certain place
if i cannot tear me from the feeling of
my body
through to the ken to stop the other
person
that's the same as my my fist coming
at the right moment
i watched the people do this and even in
real life i watch this and when they're
they have a ken in there with other
people
i can see that even when it's fast
they don't have time to think of cutting
killing striking but the actions
you can see are all meant to cut
strike thrust as if
if they had a katana a real live sword
in the hand
there wouldn't be any difference it
would be just the same
this is the total opposite to our senses
beliefs
how can you light the picture behind me
how can you have open arms
to the whole world
offering them love if you're going to
learn an art and then pick up
a wooden sword or wheel stored
and start thinking of it as a killing
machine
or set of movements where you can kill
thrust cut the person
we do the suburbs
for personal practice
and when psychosensi gave me the ken and
joe
he said tell the person
when they're a beginner
to buy a ken a joe and a ghee
if like you he said have a dojo
please put mirrors in the dojo so that
you can
practice in front of the mirrors to
check yourself
and i done this in this dojo that had
the wonderful energy
and i would go in there on my own and
this is what i'm encouraging you to do
if you don't have a dojo or mirror
find a window that will give you a
reflection
a patio door anything that will give you
a reflection
and just simply do swinging in the can
try to take out of your mind that you're
cutting anybody
or you're extending forward there must
be no
aggression whatsoever no want
of hurting anyone this is a practice
just between you and
the swing of your ken
i'm going to show you a picture of my
book
and psychosensor used to teach us a lot
outside the dojo as well as inside
i want to show you this is a common
thing that we see here
you'll see you'll notice that the arms
are very wide at the elbows
they're wider than the width of my body
i put an x on this picture to show you
that
it's wrong on the next picture
you'll see my elbows are pouring more
okay the reason
is it's important
when you're lifting your can but it's
more important
when you're coming down with your can
because
in a real situation you're going forward
when you bring your can down
the lifting you're not
so as as a test in front of the mirror
or window
as you about to come down
just draw your elbows in
sense he said if your elbows
are the width of your shoulders you
could walk through a door frame
as you cut if your elbows are wider than
your
body your elbows would get stuck on the
sides of the door frame
just a very simple analogy but i hope
one you can
understand
in time try to keep the elbows
from going wide at all so they're
contained
within you can see my shoulders
here i purposely
set the camera just for the shoulder
width
so you can see rather than my torso
if my elbows go
outside then you can see they're wider
i would never get through the door frame
as i bring them in
but i'm still looking through i bring
them to it and then i bring them down
this will give you an accurate straight
cut
you may feel that you're inside what i
call a box
you may feel tension it may feel very
tight
to you work on it
and in time it will not feel tight
because you will relax
more you won't be trying so hard to get
everything correct
once you get your suburi your first
suburi
in this natural swinging position
without extending your elbows
you've already learned a great lesson on
how to be
contained at accurate and comfortable
elbows too wide you will not get through
the door
like you know well i sense aikido is
simplicity and detail
and this is one detail that i'd like to
give you
because many of you are practicing the
weapons at the moment
do not think of killing do not think of
striking
just think of swinging the ken
in one of the early films a voice over
of a black and white film of
psychosensity says
when lost go back to basics
this is a basic movement and what you'll
find from that
is you will learn not to over extend in
many other fields
thank you for listening please subscribe
to my channel
if you're enjoying them thank you